[Musique]
comment rendre notre ville plus
attractive en inventant plus joli plus
belle tout simplement en évitant de la
salir avec nos déchets bonjour de metiga
vous êtes chargé de mission à
l'association entreprises et
environnement association fondée en 1994
et qui est connu pour son combat pour la
protection de l'environnement
cette prise de conscience de la part des
entreprises permet de faire avancer la
cause oui en effet donc cette
association a été créée en 94 en 25 ans
l'année prochaine et ce sont les
entreprises martiniquaises qui sont
adhérentes à cette association et ce
sont les entreprises qui ont créé cette
association à la base pour nettoyer les
espaces verts il ya combien
d'entreprises sont eux qui nous qui se
retrouvent dans l'entreprise
environnement pour jouer ce jeu de la
protection actuellement il est environ
80 entreprises adhérentes qui nous
aident pour nettoyer les espaces verts
il y avait également l'enlèvement des vh
huées après il y a beaucoup tout ce qui
concerne les campagnes de
sensibilisation
je me connais la campagne pays nous ce
n'est pas un pack cochon voilà donc où
les affiches avec la tortue avec le
masque donc voilà il ya aussi ce travail
de sensibilisation auprès dé martinique
alors quelles sont nos réalités sont
vraiment des malpropres ici en
martinique alors la réalité et donc nous
allons organiser donc à la 16eme
opération pays propre dans un mois et
lors des quinze éditions précédentes ce
sont 180 8 tonnes de déchets qui ont été
ramassés donc oui il y a des déchets
dénicheur martinique alors ramené par la
mer bien sûr mais déposer également par
par des habitants puisque on s'attaque à
des décharges sauvages
alors est-ce qu'on doit parler de je
m'en foutisme généralisée notamment
lorsqu'on se promène dans l'évident dans
les forêts lorsqu'on va aux abords des
rivières du canton par exemple nez à nez
ça c'est un chauffe eau solaire fasse un
faux oui en effet puisque aujourd'hui en
martinique
beaucoup beaucoup de choses ont été
mises en place pour pour jeter ses
déchets correctement il ya onze
déchetterie en martinique
la plupart sont ouvertes les week-ends
c'est gratuit donc il y à il ya aucune
excuse pour jeter alors comment elle
salue comment l'expliquer c'est de
l'éducation du civisme tout simplement
quand on est en voiture que l'on voit
quelqu'un j'étais sa bouteille par la
fenêtre mais pourtant le slogan pays à
sepang pas cochon ça avait été très très
forte mais madrid puisque on entendait
les gamins en parler comme ça en dise
est justement d'être ferme pour vraiment
sensibiliser les gens que les gens se
rendent compte eux
de leurs gestes que tous ces gestes ont
un impact énorme sur la biodiversité de
la martinique dans qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour améliorer cette
information pour améliorer cette
éducation pour améliorer cette
sensibilisation et bien surtout que les
gens participent en fait à nos actions
comme les opérations puis prof nous
avons également l'application arrêter ça
donc c'est une application sur
ordinateur ou sur portable ou son poste
des photos des décharges sauvages ont
les géo on est géolocalise et les
mairies peuvent ensuite les nettoyer en
fait le fait de participer à ces actions
les personnes peuvent se rend compte de
la réalité de voir vraiment toutes les
décharges qu'il ya donc vous donner du
travail supplémentaire aux équipes
municipales
malheureusement justement si les
personnes
ont des gestes correct il n'y aura pas
de travail mais justement on a vu lors
de cette des premières utilisations de
cette application
on a réalisé le nombre impressionnant de
ces décharges sauvages
on avait l'impression que plus on
dénonçait plus il y en avait oui alors
après parce que justement après c'est un
point positif c'est que les gens se
sentent concernés et quand ils voient
une décharge ils vont avoir le réflexe
de les géolocaliser donc c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de personnes justement qui
est qu'ils se sentent concernés et qui
vont poster des photos d'un coup on a
recensé dix mille décharge sauvage dit
il
dix mille c'est énorme dans notre petite
fille leur sit in comme la martinique
plus de 2000 ont été entièrement nettoyé
lors des opérations pied propre
également avec des grosses équipes du
matériel on qu'on s'attaque à des
décharges mais non mais ce n'est plus
possible de trouver des décharges
sauvages sur nous sur nous des huiles
sont encore à traiter
si les personnes sont capables de jeter
leurs frigos leur canapé au milieu la
mangrove je pense qu'ils sont capables
d'aller dans des décharges mais dans des
déchetteries pardon dans les
déchetteries qu il faut qu'on ramène
évoqué ses conséquences désastreuses sur
la biodiversité
quelques qui fument qui jette son mégot
par terre ça ira forcément tôt ou tard à
la mer et la catastrophe
oui en effet donc le fait d'habiter sur
une île il y à 100 % de risques les
déchets arrivent dans la mer c'est sûr
dans quelques jours quelques mois
quelques années mais les des chars ils
vont forcément dans la mer et en effet
on parle de mégots ça que les tortues
vont prendre les mégots pour des
crevettes
après on voit là pas besoin on voit les
images couvrant pas aujourd'hui pourquoi
continue-t-on c'est parce qu'on n'offre
pas d'alternative à ces fumeurs pour
qu'ils puissent après c'est une prise de
conscience
voilà son ego lieu de juste et on met
dans un cendrier on met dans une
poubelle
c'est comme les sacs plastique alors il
y en a de moins en moins heureusement
mais les sacs plastiques arrive dans la
mer les tortues les prennent pour des
méduses comme les petits cercles en
plastique ou les canettes de bière sont
mises les tortues se bloque la tête
dedans grandissent est mort étouffé
et ça on le voit avec toutes les images
heureusement qu'ils passent sur le site
on voit vraiment qu'une aux gestes sont
des catastrophes ont des conséquences
sur la sur la vie est ce que l'être
humain a conscience qu'il court à sa
perte en continuant ainsi pas assez je
pense doucement mais sûrement mais sauf
que l'on n'a plus le temps d'aller
doucement il faut vraiment réagir là on
rappelle que ils étaient plusieurs
milliers de scientifiques avoir signé
une pétition disant que dans cent
cinquante ans si on continue comme ça il
y en a marre des percements la
martinique l'humanité pourrait courir
définitivement à sa perte
parlons de la filière qu'on recyclage
que peut-on recycleurs martin vous avez
parlé de 188 tonnes de déchets collectés
lors de votre opération pays propre 190
hommes c'est beaucoup il en reste encore
beaucoup mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de
ces deux de ces déchets alors lors des
opérations puis propre en effet nous
essayons de recycler le maximum
le verre le métal tous les
électroménagers que l'on trouve dans la
nature
malheureusement les bouteilles en
plastique ramené par la mer sont trop
abîmés pour être recyclés il est très
très important de recycler en martinique
pourquoi puisque tous les déchets que
vous jeter dans la poubelle noir ces
poubelles noires vont soit
l'incinérateur soit dans les décharges
donc c'est enfouis dans la terre si on
ne recycle pas je donne un exemple les
piles les piles avec beaucoup de mercure
fin des métaux très toxique
si vous voulez jeter dans la poubelle ça
valait dans les centres d'enfouissement
donc dans la terre et tous ces éléments
toxiques
on se dissoudre dans la terre et vont
arriver dans la mer vont arriver dans
votre jardin
je pense que la terre la martinique est
bien assez pollué pour en rajouter
encore surtout que en martinique il ya
maintenant des filières de recyclage qui
sont mises en place en tant que tout
recycler en martinique les piles
les lampes tous vos électroménagers
frigo vos meubles maintenant vos
panneaux photovoltaïques et et j'en
oublie mais justement pour vos déchets
vous pouvez aller sur notre site
internet pour trouver les points de
collègues c'est www.entrepose.fr
environnement.com là vous avez les
points de collecte pour vos déchets et
lorsque vous recycler ses déchets ils
sont denses
ils vont dans un centre de démente de
démantèlement et les éléments toxiques
sont détruits de façon convenable et
ensuite on utilise le matériel pour
recycler et pour fabriquer d'autres
objets alors on se souvient que votre
association créée en 1994 avec
aujourd'hui 80 entreprises avaient pour
objet de s'occuper des espaces verts
d'entretenir les ronds-points et
aujourd'hui tous ces entreprises
viennent vers vous parce qu'elles ont
pris conscience que et il ya un petit
peu plus de choses à faire que cela
oui hélas l'association a également pris
vraiment de la notoriété donc jeudi des
espaces verts les enlèvements des vh su
également et donc oui en effet il nous
aide vraiment à participer au bien-être
de la martinique ont dit il ce filières
de recyclage sont avec vous aujourd'hui
oui alors suite à la création de
l'entreprise il ya par exemple les
constructeurs auto ou les un porteur de
pneus qui ont contacté entreprises
environnement pour créer des filières de
recyclage ce qui a donné et aider à
batterie août et des apps ne recycle
également les pneus les batteries donc
ce serait de l'emploi ici en martinique
ça crée de l'emploi
et ça crée également des solutions pour
pour les habitants et suite à ça c'est
sont les filières de recyclage qui nous
ont contactés pour que entreprises
environnement soient leurs représentants
sur le territoire de la martinique vu
dans la presse dernièrement la
protection de l'environnement pourrait
crier 18 millions d'emplois en france en
martinique ça on peut être dans cette
dynamique toutes proportions gardées
oui bien sûr on voit que
que l'environnement touche de plus en
plus de monde et également les gens
travaillent de plus en plus on voit sur
les sargasses les personnes c'est un
problème qui arrive en martinique et des
personnes vont devoir travailler là
dessus donc en effet c'est une création
d'emplois yens il nous reste quelques
secondes de metiga cette question
épineuse de la protection de
l'environnement
ça doit passer par l'éducation parentale
tous sont des parents qui doivent
enseigner les bons gestes oui en effet
vraiment les enfants sont bien sûr sont
laissés l'avenir de notre martinique et
si nous voulons que nos enfants
continuent à avoir des tortues avoir pu
voir les tortues
oui c'est vraiment une prise de
conscience qui doit se faire tout petit
et les parents vraiment un énorme rôle à
jouer envers leurs enfants rien le geste
à montrer voilà lorsque l'on acheté une
bouteille par par la fenêtre de sa
voiture avec notre enfant derrière c'est
le geste que l'on veut inculquer à nos
enfants donc je n'ai pas possible
quelles sont ces objets de la vie au
quotidien qui sont des plus dangereux
pour la protection de l'environnement
c'est la paille lorsqu'on prend une
boisson c'est le coton tige c'est we are
malheureusement on voit beaucoup dans
les salons de sensibilisation tout le
monde a déjà jeter un papier mais voilà
un papier qu est ce que c est sais pas
mais tout le monde se dit çà et et tous
ces gestes ont des conséquences alors
oui ça avec le petit coton tige qui va
arriver dans les narines des poissons
des tortues mais ça va être une pile qui
va polluer notre terre ça va être un
mégot qui va être avalés par la suite
par des poissons mais faut pas oublier
que les poissons c'est nous qui les
mangent ont par la suite donc on s'auto
détruit en fait merci beaucoup d'hommes
et tiga diaries est avec nous on
rappelle que vous êtes chargé de mission
sept associations entreprises et
environnement et que dans un mois il y
aura cette opération pays propre ce sera
la seizième édition nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler bonne journée